EÊtre jugé par ses pairs,
c'c'est un droit fondamental
dodont peut se prévaloir un accé
dedevant la Cour supérieure.
C'C'est un devoir lourd de
reresponsabilités, être juré.
EnEn cette Semaine d'appréciatin
dudu jury au Canada, on
s's'entretient avec la sénatrice
LuLucie Moncion, qui a présenté
unune motion au Sénat en faveur
dede cet événement.
M Mme Moncion, bonjour.
- - Bonjour.
- - Vous avez vous-même été jure
dadans un procès pour meurtre au
1e1er degré il y a 30 ans. Qu'e-
cece qui vous a le plus marquée?
- - C ce dont on hérite d'une
sisituation comme celle-là.
PePendant la durée du procès, on
esest devant des photos, on nous
momontre toutes sortes de choses
ququi sont quand même assez
didifficiles à voir. Vous arrivz
llà-dedans, vous ne connaissez
papas du tout le milieu juridiq.
VoVous ne connaissez pas le
fofonctionnement de la cour, vos
vovous retrouvez devant des piès
àà conviction qui sont assez
inintimidantes. On vous présente
dedes photos, des vidéos, des
chchoses qui sont assez difficis
àà voir et ensuite vous indique
quque vous ne pouvez pas parlere
cece que vous voyez, de ce que
vovous entendez. Ça crée cette
esespèce de culture de silence t
lolorsqu'on quitte à la fin du
prprocès, le juge nous indique e
l'l'on ne peut parler de ce qui
s's'est passé dans les
dédélibérations, ce qui se compe
avavec ce bagage d'horreur, pare
ququ'en grande partie c'est ce
ququ'il nous reste, et on ne pet
papas en parler à personne. Ça a
dedes effets pervers sur notre
cocomportement dans les mois qui
susuivent la fin du procès.
- - Qu'ils ont été les
coconséquences pour vous?
- - Avant que je comprenne
l'l'origine, c'était des colère,
ququi se manifestait de façon ts
spspontanée et elles étaient de
plplus en plus récurrentes,
jujusqu'à ce qu'un jour mon mari
didise : Bloin d'aller faire
sosoigner. J'ai été sous le choà
cece moment-là et j'y suis allé.
CÇa m'a aidé beaucoup et lorsque
j'j'ai compris l'origine du
prproblème, je voudrais que ça à
rérégler la situation. Ça laisse
unune grande tristesse et je
dedeviens émotive facilement sie
rereparle de ce procès dans
cecertaines situations.
- - Ça donne accès non seulement
dedes images mais des concepts t
dedes idées au quel peu de gens
onont accès en général. De quele
fafaçon pensez-vous que les jurs
popourraient être mieux encadré
popour cette tâche?
- - On recommande un accès à
d'd'autres services. Lorsque les
gegens ont terminé le travail de
jujury, c'est de pouvoir
paparticiper à des sessions de
dédébris Eiffage. On a fait des
sosondages auprès d'anciens
memembres de jury et quand les
gegens sont retournés chez eux,
totous disaient qu'il se sentait
seseul et isolé, ils avaient dea
didifficulté à revenir à leur ve
nonormale, parce que les gens
auautour de ne comprenait pas ce
ququi s'était passé. Les gens
babanalisés le fait qu'ils aient
étété jurys. Donc des sciences e
dédébris Eiffage. De l'accès à s
seservices de thérapie ou d'écoe
2424 heures par jour, sept jours
papar semaine, lorsque les membs
dudu jury en ont besoin pour
didiscuter de certaines choses u
papasser une émotion. Ou tout
sisimplement pour comprendre ce
ququi se passe. Il y a aussi de
réréféré les gens qui entourent
leles membres des jurys pour ête
enen mesure de les aider au momt
ouoù ils sont en train de
dédélibérer ou pendant les proc.
IlIl y a toute la question de la
cocompensation financière. Il ya
bebeaucoup d'employeurs qui ne
papaient pas leurs employés
lolorsqu'ils sont appelés à être
jujurés. On demande aux provincs
dede regarder des façons de
cocorriger cette situation. Il a
unune dizaine de situations come
cecelle-là qui sont rémunérés ds
leles propositions qu'on fait au
gogouvernement.
- - La question de la rémunératn
rerevient souvent. L'indemnité u
QuQuébec et 203 $ par jo